the margin presented a target of
opportunity for us look like I said this
is my fourth term and I'm tired of the
way this place works I think it's deeply
corrupt I think the lobbyists run the
show most of the times I think people
are more interested in servicing their
Pac fundraiser than they are the needs
of their constituents and it's a grift
game and the way that what facilitates
that grift game is an entire
sophisticated structure that ensures
that no one's really responsible for the
legislating
thank you
foreign
we're still in DC I'm still Dave Rubin
it's still the Reuben report and joining
me today is the congressman from
Florida's first district and the first
time Reuben report guest was just really
bizarre to me Matt Gates Matt how are
you thanks for having me this is weird
to me that we've never sat down before I
feel like you've been fighting with
everybody I feel like I know you because
I watch the show so how am I doing great
I mean you're getting the message out
killing it in the hair game that's
really what I want to focus on mostly
you know when Dave Bratt lost in
Virginia it was sad to see a colleague I
respected go but that was when I got the
best hair in Congress and so you know
there's there's some up-and-comers Kylie
out of California he's got great great
hair great height I'm worried about him
is that mostly what's going on behind
the scenes like everyone's like who has
the best hair who has the worst hair
plugs that's pretty much what's
happening I wish there was a border Bill
up how about that for uh for a lead I
wish that uh we were talking about
internal enforcement and Asylum reform
one thing that frustrates me a little is
that we've passed two bills that deal
with the borders of Indian tribes and
not yet a bill to deal with the border
of our country so I wouldn't give our
Congress an A-Plus yet until we get the
work of the people done I like it you're
going right into the issues so let's
let's do it right there uh well actually
give me give me one minute on just Matt
Gates 101 for the people that just don't
know your history at all and then and
then we'll get into the all the
specifics I'm a country lawyer from
North Florida served in our state
legislature proudly for six years I
chaired what was the equivalent of our
Ways and Means Committee fought for low
taxes good regulatory reform I was
probably a more libertarian leaning
member of the State House than I am of
uh of the Congress but when President
Trump was running I I the juices started
to stir it I do a little more for my
country I ran got here I'm in my fourth
term now and eager to continue the work
I think that we've got one half of
one-third of the government right now
and every day is really a test and how
how to exercise leverage effectively and
you can overplay that and underplay that
but we're working to curate that balance
in a way that that makes life better for
people so let's talk about that leverage
for a minute because just about two
hours ago I had Congressman Dan Crenshaw
in here and you guys were obviously on
opposite sides of everything that went
down with uh with McCarthy and the
leadership but that was my whole purpose
of coming to DC I wanted to sit down
with guys that were on every every side
of every issue so you basically led the
the fight against McCarthy was that were
you planning on doing that did it just
kind of materialize out of nowhere and
then did it become like a monster unto
itself once once it started well I think
there were a lot of people who took
leadership roles on on different issue
sets not every person required the same
concessions to allow McCarthy to ascend
to the speakership some people are more
fiscal Hawks some people are more border
Hawks some people are over side Hawks
and So within those different groups
there were a lot of voices that emerged
and so I went characterize myself the
leader but we realized the opportunity
in the media at least kind of framed you
as like you you were kind of the media
does like talking about me what's
happening hang out with the orange guy a
lot there's a lot you know come on well
you know he's a fun guy to hang out with
so you know the the margin presented a
target of opportunity for us look like I
said this is my fourth term and I'm
tired of the way this place works I
think it's deeply corrupt I think the
lobbyists run the show most of the times
I think people are more interested in
servicing their Pac fundraiser than they
are the needs of their constituents and
it's a grift game and the way that what
facilitates that grift game is an entire
sophisticated structure that ensures
that no one's really responsible for the
legislating right if we had to take
individual votes on individual
departments and authorizations
and bills and spending then we would
probably be be held to account to a
greater degree by the people in this
country but instead what you get is
every year or so some multi-thousand
page bill that you get a day day and a
half to read and the whole deal is
thumbs up or thumbs down on the whole
thing and then you're left with the
decision of you know voting for a bunch
of crap you don't agree with or leaving
out the widows and the orphans and the
veterans in the military and things that
every American would care about and we
had to force upon the system a better
way to deal with legislating as an
Enterprise and that had features in
policy features and personnel and
features in procedure and that's what
we're working through so I heard you on
Tim Poole's podcast talking about just
that these massive bills that you get
and that nobody can read it as you just
laid out and it's a whole bunch of stuff
but you know if you don't vote for it
someone's gonna die and all that so I
want to talk about the specifics of that
but did you feel like you actually at
the end got the concessions and how do
you know that you're actually going to
get them you know what I mean like is
that do you have a piece of paper that's
sitting in your office you in McCarthy
like well I mean yeah the ultimate
accountability tool isn't a piece of
paper the accountability tools that any
one member can go and force a vote on
the speaker at any time and you know
throw it so that was the main concession
well that was that was the enforcement
tool for the other substantive
concessions right but you I mean I'll
gladly go into the substance of these
things sure and sure we add documents
that we exchanged back and forth with
offers and suggestions and revisions and
in any negotiation you never get exactly
what you want but you know I I recall
going into the speaker's office with uh
Scott Perry and Lauren bobert before the
balloting began and we laid out what we
thought was a pretty reasonable proposal
to the speaker and he laughed at us and
said well we just you know wanted the
opportunity to have that power but that
resided in the speaker not in our group
and then ultimately we got to something
that was far better than we than had
been rejected and ultimately far better
for the House of Representatives and I
don't say that as a criticism of
McCarthy I actually think it's two is
great credit that he was willing to see
past a reflexive opposition to things
like the the one member motion to vacate
the chair he had originally said that
was a red line he would never cross it
he would never go there and had he been
stubborn about that he probably wouldn't
be speaker and it would have been worse
for the country and for the house and
for the party so his ability to I think
move past his red lines started that
process of building trust what do you
make how it creates strange bedfellows
out of people so for example you know
Trump is backing McCarthy but you're a
trump guy you're going against McCarthy
the base doesn't seem to like McCarthy
but the base loves Trump like there were
so many just like odd pieces to the
whole thing I guess I mean you know
we're we're complicated people no two
people see everything the same I know
people view me as a Trump Acolyte and
certainly I spend time with the former
president I like him I support him but
even president Trump and I see some
issues differently and when you have a
high intensity negotiation different
people can go to different corners and
make different demands and I think
ultimately we got to a good result but I
I don't believe that anyone deserves
praise yet because
all we have developed is a toolkit and
it's a toolkit that's really unlike any
I've ever had as a member of Congress
but if all we do is admire the tools and
talk about how great it was that we got
the tools and what a negotiation
delivered the tools to the toolkit we
don't use them
then we are part of the fraudulent
system that screws people over so how do
you want to use the tools it started you
know today you're in DC if you go over
to the Capitol start chatting with these
guys like how do you want to actually
exercise this stuff well one that's got
me a little worked up as we're having
this discussion is the Border there's a
commitment that speaker McCarthy made
that the Border plan that had been
previously endorsed by the Texas
delegation would be coming to the floor
and right now we add our border we don't
even have a border vote scheduled in
Committee in the house Judiciary
Committee we were supposed to right now
be preparing for an upcoming hearing and
the immigration bills were taken off the
agenda so I'm a little frustrated about
that I I want to give Grace and
deference where it's due if there are
some details still to work out but one
substantive concession is to get a bill
to the floor that says that we detain
people if we have the space or we turn
them away it's HR 29
and uh you know we uh we need to get to
that the business of doing that the
other is the budget
we have to start moving individual
Appropriations bills to the floor so we
can evaluate every agency every layer of
every agency that that has to start
getting scheduled in the Appropriations
Committee we were promised to vote on
term limits I I think that a lot of
these things by the way are going to
fail that I'm asking for terminals vote
will fail right the the real changes to
secure the Border might fail if Pro
amnesty Republicans don't hang with us
bottom line is I'm okay with that you
see the leadership in both parties have
this view that it's this great
embarrassment and this great tumult if
you put something on the floor that
doesn't have the votes I actually think
that can be revealing and sometimes you
have to go through an iterative process
to get to a good work product and
whether it's Obamacare or any number of
other bills that don't get that that
scrutiny you end up with all these
terrible unintended consequences if you
don't do it so when you talk about these
freaking Giants they're not like this
they're actually like almost to the
ceiling hi some of these things so they
hand this to you and
you basically don't know who's written
it right or it's lobbyists that have
half written it I know it's written it
it's the interest groups yeah so okay
yeah I mean the way what this town runs
on are the interest groups that plow
money into the political system and it's
more sophisticated than that but that is
really the rock upon which they built
their church but it's also like in a lot
of these offices you get underpaid staff
working for the taxpayer and a lot of
them their dream is to go work as
lobbyists or for these interest groups
so they end up uh in some places
becoming The Valleys of the special
interests now fortunately my staff is a
we're a pirate ship so everybody comes
on board and understands that we got we
got a different kind of mission but in a
lot of places that is actually part of
the swamp that that concerns me but
they're able to hide in that corrupt
system if you have individual scrutiny
of the bills you get to flush out all
the varmin and then you know what
happens and you know getting Personnel
appointed is another critical thing for
conservatives we have people like Thomas
Massey chip Roy Ralph Norman who we
trust do not fall victim to that system
they have long histories of standing up
for their constituents and so we put the
three of them on the rules committee now
guess what before stuff gets to the
floor we're working out our issues in
advance we're getting some of the pork
and special favors for the lobby Corps
weed it out and and then on the
Appropriations Committee
we also demanded spots for additional
conservatives we demanded that one of
our existing members have reigns over a
subcommittee to be able to constrain
some of the social spending so I mean
these are real concessions that speaker
McCarthy has delivered on and then we've
just got a lot of other stuff just
dating in the pipeline and as you can
tell I'm anxious to get that done
what do you think the Republicans can do
to message this stuff better because
it's I've been telling all my guests and
I've sat down I'm going to sit down with
with chip and and Thomas tomorrow we've
had Ron Johnson was here today I'm
sitting down with as many people as I
can and one of the things that seems odd
to me is that Peter Thiel always says we
have we have the evil party in the
stupid party and it's like the Democrats
are the evil party obviously but then
there's this other party that as
frustrated as people may be with them
they just don't seem to want to cross
that divide what do you think
Republicans can do on that you know we
Face Exquisite headwinds the censorship
industrial complex is real and actually
we're using the power we have in the
weaponization subcommittee also a
concession part that was a part of the
speaker's race to expose that censorship
industrial complex to haul the people
forward that really are the Puppet
Masters that engage in the shadow
Banning and the programming of the
mainstream media and the government
threats to big Tech that shape what
people see and what they believe so it's
hard to talk about the efficacy of one's
message when you're not talking about
the systems that proliferate that
message so I think that that is a a
threshold issue you have to address look
in turn you always want a movement with
the best messages and the best
Messengers and fortunately for us the
the left is somewhere between like a a
nursing home escape and a carnival freak
Show yeah and so we've got a lot of
Running Room and I actually think we
have great messages I mean you you
mentioned Dan Crenshaw earlier there are
a lot of issues that he and I see
differently in the house but that's a
guy who knows how to carry a message he
does so effectively I admire that about
him he actually said the same thing
about you yeah so there you go yeah and
I think that
um right now the interesting exercise
we're in with a four-seat majority is we
have to think about things that can that
we can unify behind that go from Matt
gates to you know a Mike Lawler or a
Brian Fitzpatrick or a David valadeo
someone more in the political Center and
acknowledging that and working through
that actually makes us stronger as a
team going forward I don't say that as
some some cheeky it you look at
the debt limit that we have right now
what are we going to demand as a part of
the negotiation on the debt limit I've
proposed demanding work requirements on
a lot of these social safety net
programs not because that's the only
thing I'd like to do I'd like to zero
out the Federal Department of Education
I'd like to zero out the ATF
throughout the Department of Labor right
I'd like to do all those things but I
recognize that those demands are likely
to fizzle in the broader construct we
find ourselves in with Biden the White
House and with the Senate and Democrat
hands and so what are the ways that we
can juxtapose Joe Biden not to me but to
Bill Clinton who was willing to sit down
and work out work requirements so that's
how a four seat majority informs on like
the real-time decisions we're making
this week about a consequential issue
like the debt limit so I've asked this
of everybody that's coming in here I
mean you mentioned how it's what do you
say it's an old age home and a clown
circus something like that or a freak
Show it's like is there anyone is there
anyone to talk to that you can work with
on on things oh sure you know on the
other side yeah yeah I mean there are uh
there are people in both parties uh to
whom it is worthless to speak because
they are vessels through which the
special interests operate and the only
thing that's going to guide them is some
corrupt influence sometimes it's
campaign money sometimes it's some
family member of theirs that gets a
no-show job that that enhances their
lifestyle sometimes it's what their
stock portfolio looks like but you know
there are also very good people on both
sides I would say that um want to move
the country forward increasingly I think
there are too many Democrats who
actually explicitly root against the
country and they believe that is
virtuous because they think that if
America is weakened as a nation that
somehow we will treat each other better
and be more just and they're actually
just as dumb as the neocons who believe
that you can go behind every Middle
Eastern Sand Dune and build some
Jeffersonian democracy after a regime
change War I'm not for regime change uh
you know there and I'm not I'm not for
changing
um the fundamentals of American life
that have made us the Envy of the world
I think that the deconstruction is
occurring on the left right now to the
family to the education setting to law
and enforcement and as conservatives we
have to unite to resist that do you
think there's anything that the
Democrats can do to reverse that or do
you think that ship has sailed meaning
you know we played a clip this morning
don't invite me to their Bunko party yes
but uh you know we played a club this
morning it's like AOC you guys passed
the parents rights and education thing
and she's calling it fascism Hakeem
Jeffries is saying they don't want to
teach about the hawk I was like it's
just like lies and craziness like is
there anyone in there that can sort of
stem that or do you think that's just
about broadly I don't know the answer to
that question but I do think we have to
be willing to create alliances around
issue sets where we may have a common
ground take for example the surveillance
state that we have I get real squeamish
about the powers that the Patriot Act
and other laws have fused into the
National Security State to deprive
Americans of their Liberties often in
the absence of constitutional
protections and I can find Democrats
like Zoe Loftin and on the Judiciary
Committee or rokana in the Progressive
delegation who will actually work with
me to try to build enduring coalitions
against an establishment that also
includes both Republicans and Democrats
I I don't know why we're in Syria I
think that that is a foolish Conquest
for the United States I think that our
service members are sitting ducks in in
many cases guarding oil rigs where for
relatively low cost the Iranians can
send lethal drone strikes so I force a
vote on whether or not to withdraw from
Syria I get 20 minutes of time the
Republicans get 20 minutes of time the
Democrats get 20 minutes of time all of
the time controlled by each of the
parties was given to people to debate in
favor of America staying in Syria right
and it shows you on on some of these
issues from surveillance to foreign
policy how it's not really the red team
against the blue team it's more about
the establishment against the the rest
of us you must be kind of proud that it
does seem at least from what I can tell
that the the anti-war sentiment does
seem to be picking up that you know even
if you watch the way when when Tucker
took all the statements from the
presidential candidates about Ukraine
you know and DeSantis was a little more
in the Trump Camp than people wanted
then he slightly moved on it but the
fact that the whole machine came he was
right I mean you're you're like a
DeSantis Apostle why is it that Ron
moved away from the the America first
position and had to start sounding more
like Piers Morgan it's interesting and
people can watch my video from the next
day I thought the statement on uh on
Tucker was perfect I actually thought it
was basically perfect like it's a
territorial dispute we can't solve all
the world's problems and we got our own
problems like that seemed good enough to
me
um I should say I'm not a surrogate for
him or anything so it is what it is
um he moved off it a little bit what did
he say after he's like yeah I'm not even
sure but I know yeah yeah
the peers interview he said he said war
criminal and I think that's what got
everybody he said Putin's a war criminal
and he started to Parrot some McCain
Romney lines also the gas station line
that was the big one yeah
I don't know I don't know what do you
think
I think that DeSantis probably had the
right energy in the Tucker interview
more than in the Piers Morgan interview
and uh you know he and I served together
in in the Congress and I
enthusiastically supported his campaign
for governor served as his transition
chair when he took the position uh very
proud of the work that he's done in
Florida but we always would squabble a
bit over foreign policy because he he
had I'd read his book and it leaned a
little more into the the boltonista view
of the world than my view of the world
and so we would we would have a friendly
squabbles about foreign policy at times
and his very bright he understands the
the world very well but I have a
different view of what
America's focus should be and when we
try to become the world's policeman and
the world's piggy bank not only does
that drain us of our treasure and the
blood of our bravest Patriots it's often
counterproductive yeah I'll be totally
honest I mean and this is what I said to
Crenshaw who I happen to agree more with
you on this than Crenshaw like to me if
nothing else putting aside all of the
policies we are governed by a bunch of
complete morons at the moment basically
so why would I trust they can't do
anything right here why would I trust
that we can just endlessly give money
across the world and that's going to fix
any big fights even if you put aside the
philosophic isolationist versus you know
doing stuff policy yeah and I I also get
to have spirited intelligent uh debates
with Mr Crenshaw on the subject and I
enjoy those and I appreciate his
perspective you know but you look at our
military now
during the Afghanistan withdrawal the
fact that they sequenced it incorrectly
the fact that they didn't Downstream the
authority to the American snipers to
take out the suicide bomber resulted in
the loss of 13 lives then we didn't even
get the Redemption right when when we
were going to go have the Vengeance
killing against the Isis guys who were
planning the plot against Americans we
accidentally killed a family in a van so
like if Taiwan is invaded by China and
we get in the fight are we going to miss
and hit Japan right I I look at our
military right now and I'm inspired
every day by the folks who put the
uniform on and love our nation but they
are not well served by the clowns who
are making the calls at the senior
levels of the Pentagon what do these
guys get right they told us that they
told us that the ghani government was
going to stay and fight for at least six
months and they told me they told us
that the ukrainians were going to be
gone in six weeks
do you trust these people to make
accurate assessments about literally
anything at this point no I don't so the
other thing I've been asking everybody
is do you think this is incompetence or
willful uh
destruction of everything that makes
sense how about that I struggle with
that decision because honestly I I try
to not judge people's motives but at
some point you know the good book says
you have to judge the tree by the fruit
and I'm I'm looking at the decision
calculus and what it leads to and it is
just Unworthy of my constituents who
will go anywhere and fight anyone
because they love this country and they
don't ask the tough questions they do
whatever they're told and so it is
incumbent upon us to be willing to ask
those questions and when secretary
defense and the chairman come before the
house armed services committee I'll I
think I'll be asking some tough
questions so I think one thing that
people see is okay so you bring out a
bunch of people to talk about big Tech
the Twitter Executives or this one or
that one and we expose some of the
nonsense but nothing ever happens after
right that it's just like okay wow you
got the guy who's traded the email with
the FBI agent to censor somebody but
then the next day it's like everyone
still has their jobs nobody really you
know no winning government was hauled
out so what about that like what about
getting some of the people that were
doing some of the surveillance stuff
that was involved with Twitter and
Facebook and everything else and and
getting them to testify are those the
people that should be testifying not
just the kind of half-assed Twitter
executive who what was or wasn't doing
the best they could well I think that's
what we're building to yeah yeah my
assessment is that is that that that is
precisely how this investigation
crescendos the people in our government
who believe that they should substitute
their judgment about what is true or
false about what is disinformation or
not for the Judgment of Americans who I
think actually can compare sources and
review information like the the pro
censorship crowd they have such a low
view of the rest of us they have to be
there to protect us well actually that's
not how it works at all and when you ask
about consequences the United States
Congress cannot go throw handcuffs on
anyone and that's probably for pretty
good reason right now we have a justice
department that is pretty recalcitrant
to any referral that we make even if
these people tell us to get bent when we
send them subpoenas that'll be an
interesting fight and so we have to go
through this accommodation process to
try to bleed out of the Executive Branch
the people the records the admissions
that I think make the case so that's the
real question is how to use the leverage
which I believe is the power of the
subpoena and the power of the purse that
is what speaker McCarthy said in his
acceptance speech and it was beautiful
and it's true
and so we cannot continue to fund this
weaponized government against our people
if those authorities stay in place and
if we do not bake into any budget deal a
restriction on what they're able to do
to us what about the fact that it seems
like so few people that are asking the
questions that these hearings have any
freaking clue what they're talking about
like you you Mo it's almost on
everything but I would say when it comes
to healed me all the time is that that's
what you're saying right that's a lot
they could just send me the time Jordan
there's a bunch of good ones Mike
Johnson done Bishop you know Harriet
Hageman we got a lot of good ones but
yeah no she's a she's something else
she's very effective yeah uh but really
like when especially with the tech stuff
you get these people up there that
clearly don't even know how to open up
an app on their phone and they're like
it's just so stupid I mean we are not
going to be able to defeat big Tech if
our leader is on the front line are not
digital natives that's why this next
Generation coming behind me is so
important to win the battle against big
Tech and to win the battles against
against transhumanism that are not even
fully emerging yet right and so we I
view the the geriatric Millennials among
us as really the bridge to try to start
the fires that the Zoomers behind us
will have to really take up because it
it fundamentally shapes their life but
yeah if you've been if you've been
waiting around Millennial that's a gen
zero no a geriatric Millennials like the
old Millennial like the first
Millennials right you know so we're
having to put gen Z then well gen Zia
they're the Zoomers they're behind us
oh I'm sorry not gen Z I mean Gen X oh
yeah Gen X what happened to us yeah no
Genex you're you're you you guys listen
to all the metal bands and and you're
not really digital natives at all right
I mean you Gen X actually believes that
you should come to work early and stay
late and that the way you moved up in
the world was by working harder you you
guys were getting into the workforce in
the Reagan 80s the Gen xers have no idea
how to talk to the Zoomers who show up
and say like I'd like to discuss my
work-life balance with you it's totally
foreign to the Gen uh the Gen xers but
for us
here's the key policy question
do you carve up big Tech in the courts
or do you reshape these companies
legislatively and frankly it's what
divides people like me and Jim Jordan
right the Jim Jordan approach would be
strip them of their immunities like
section 230 and then allow the trial
lawyers to go Feast on them it's kind of
like what we did to Big tobacco in the
90s and I just don't know if that is
enough Firepower to shoot at the Death
Star that is big Tech I believe we have
to go more the direction of the bell
break up in Telecom where you literally
Force but you use force of law to say
that meta has to alienate Instagram you
say that Google has to alienate YouTube
and you have to reshape and break up
these companies without going through
the the litigation process for another
seven eight years is this where you
would say that old school republicanism
just uh kind of doesn't work we play we
played a clip on my show about two three
weeks ago where Mike Pence was on CNBC
saying well DeSantis went too far by
taking away some special rights from
Disney and it was like well wait a
minute gave Disney those rights exactly
exactly and I and I it just read to me
as so out of touch with what people want
right like he didn't uh there's also Sea
World they don't what is the
constituency for Mike Pence right I'm
just wondering other than Sunday show
Bookers and uh like CNN and the
mainstream media who are the people you
don't I don't think so I think he knows
that there's no I don't know anyone I
don't know anyone what is that okay I'm
I'm wondering where I've got to go to
meet the Mike Pence voter maybe Mike
pets house I you might must wait all
right so you're a Florida Congressman
you're you're tauren with the freaking
red asked where do you get the jacket
like that that red jacket oh I lifted it
off of a Mater D on the way into the
event
I actually believe you is that I do
believe you but okay
um no so you're look you're you're a
Florida Congressman you obviously like
DeSantis but you're you're doing your
thing with Trump
from where I sit as someone that lived
in Cali moved to Florida my life is
immeasurably better I brought two
companies here that are both flourishing
every one of my guys over here all moved
everyone is seeing the fruits of all of
that standard you could vote for any
Republican governor in America
no at Wells I could certainly go to any
Republican state and be better than it
was in Cali sure sure for sure
um I'm just seeing everything work in
Florida so how how do you balance that
in that you live in a state that clearly
the governor's doing the right thing you
got the super majorities you want and
it's cooking and then also obviously
that you like Trump and he obviously has
unfinished business and that whole thing
well I am a DeSantis admirer I worked
very hard to get him elected but Florida
has been under unified Republican
control since the mid 90s and so there
there has been a system in place in
Florida to advance school choice to have
right-sized environmental regulations to
not overspend on the state budget to
care for our seniors in the vulnerable
and Ron DeSantis has done an Exquisite
job as Governor leading that Enterprise
I know because I worked with him as his
transition chairman and helped him hire
some of the great Floridians who have
helped him enact bold policies
the time is is right for Trump in
Washington right now because that is a
different fight being able to
successfully steer a successful State
and to chart a bold course is something
I'm glad Ron's doing I hope he continues
to do it for his full eight years
this place
needs somebody to come in with a sense
of Retribution and a sense of of uh I
think fight that is unique to president
Trump and being in Waco this last
weekend seeing the tens of thousands of
people show up there's something unique
about Trump and politics that I think we
need to have even a chance against what
we face electorally so I'll say to you
what I've been saying all along on my
show which is again I like them both if
it ends up that Trump is the president
and DeSantis remains my Governor I'll be
freaking thrilled that that might be the
best situation truly and as a Floridian
I can fully make an argument that he
shouldn't run like I I fully get all
that
um but what I would like to see out of
trump right now since you have his ear
is that you don't have to destroy the
guy like he's trying to do it it seems
to me that the nicknames are not working
that the pretending you don't think
meatball Ron worked not really look it
can you didn't John Oliver thought it
were this is a hot today I agree with I
don't agree with John Oliver I don't
agree with John a lot but uh
it might be the best of all of them but
like the sanctimonious like come on it
doesn't work he's not sanctimonious like
I don't I'm not sure Trump knows what
the word means like look sometimes you
got to go through a few iterations on
the nickname the game before you land at
one okay but putting aside the nickname
the point of like trying to destroy the
guy that is the standard bearer of of a
republican as Governor I think is just
misguided I think that that's misguided
I get politics is nasty yeah nobody
pitches underhand here it's the
presidency yeah you know I I think that
uh you know when someone
I'm telling you I'm hearing a lot of
that I'm sure none of us like that I
don't none of us like when folks we
admire are disagreeing and fighting with
one another but I certainly don't
begrudge either for engaging that in
that Enterprise because it's competitive
look at me you know how you get the
strongest Lions because if there's a
strong male lion and he comes up on a
less strong male lion that's got some
female lines around he kills the male
lion and mates with the females right
that's how it goes in the animal kingdom
and I'm not entirely sure that politics
is all that much different every now and
again you end up with a bunch of dead
lions and then right right Democrats in
power which is a bigger problem probably
yeah they're the hyenas I think in my
metaphor exactly
um
what's next what's next for you I mean
you're gonna you're gonna fight as this
thing's going it seems like Republicans
are kind of moving a little bit you got
some stuff out of McCarthy I'm thinking
this down yeah I'm thinking very short
term I'm thinking let's get a good deal
on the debt limit that does not bankrupt
this country uh I'm you know looking
after that at an Appropriations process
that I hope will reset the table for a
decade long past my time here as a
congressman and I hope that the things
that I fought for during the speakers
race will become the expectation and the
Baseline going forward and that the Next
Generation can come in with even better
ideas about how to empower the
membership and how to really expose the
extent to which
we don't get to make decisions on far
too many matters that are of great
consequence to our constituents and we
got to do a better job fixing that and I
want to use the tools in the toolkit I'm
tired of staring at them um I often get
get chastised by my colleagues that I'm
impatient and I feel the anxiousness of
that in this moment
that probably should be the ending but I
feel like I got to ask you one more
because now having sat with you for the
I mean again the first time that we ever
met or anything you know if you listen
to the mainstream media talk about you
you're some kind of far right or like
it's all nonsense of course they say
that about all of us so why do you think
they hate me so much I've wondered this
I I don't fret over right now it's
probably just like enough you're around
Trump enough that it's like it doesn't
matter yeah it just doesn't matter what
you say but I mean they think I'm far
right too like I mean oh yeah you get it
too I mean New York Times literally
front page of the Sunday New York Times
said I was one of the leaders of the all
right so I could be better than being
one of the followers I guess yeah I
guess exactly at least then you have
some ability to move them or something
um but what about that portion of it
that you're also fighting it's not just
that you're fighting sort of a deep
State and a system that's screwy and
Democrats that have kind of lost their
minds but also just like a media that is
just so far from the truth that it makes
just the messaging part of it incredibly
difficult uh when when members get to
this town and they go through the first
barrage of unfair media criticism I try
to advise them don't let the process be
the punishment
and often that's what that's why the
media does what they do they want to
shape our legislative goals they want to
shape the things that we're allowed to
talk about in civil society and I just
don't give in to the construct and I
actually have a far higher view of my
fellow Americans than I think the media
does because I think people see through
the I think people know who's
fighting for them and who isn't and in a
town where a lot of the politicians are
just actors reading the scripts from
lobbyists and staff who want to become
lobbyists I think people will forgive
you a mistake and an occasional
disagreement if they feel you are
sincere and that you care about them and
that you're actually fighting for them
and that's how you spend your time so I
try to convey that in the work I do I
know the media conveys something else
but I continue to get overwhelmingly
re-elected and I I really am heartened
by the prayers that I get that I feel
from all over this country from folks
who want to see that our work is done
not not for my sake but for that theirs
I know we may not see totally eye to eye
on on everything but from one Floridian
to another it's been a pleasure thanks
for having me man if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell